foreign
last season on Savage Kingdom
[Music]
Saba watches her daughter die
in the jaws of a ruthless rifle
matsumi claws her way to power
second Karma murders his own son
[Music]
now Griff on the throne is slipping
thank you
There Will Be Blood
[Music]
foreign
king of beasts
rallies his three Rising Sons
Time to Kill
with this much muscle they target Giants
ah
[Music]
foreign
part
[Music]
the princes showed promise
father is at the top of his game
[Music]
in this world
sakakama is God
his sons make him proud
United his family is Unstoppable
thank you
it's a deadly Gamble
youth has ambition
and arrogance
sakakama sees trouble Brewing
these princes have stayed too long
do not
cross me
foreign
[Music]
thank you
Saba fears the Marsh pride from bitter
experience
they butchered her daughter
Neo is all she has left
with her help
he may one day rule leopard Rock
foreign
[Music]
the heavens open
prime hunting season is here
but Neo has so much to learn
Saba must turn her innocent kitten
into a ruthless killer
she will shape his destiny
oh yeah
foreign
calls to Arms
[Music]
is mine
all challenges be warned
[Music]
his message carries to the Wasteland of
the North
here three angry lionesses plot their
Revenge
they hate the Marsh pride even more than
Saba does
they were exiled by their enemies with
nothing
now these Outlaws want vengeance
they are building an empire
with eight secret weapons
[Music]
four sons and four daughters
future Fighters
and future mothers
the foundation of the next great Dynasty
[Music]
within the north will rise
and the Marsh pride will fall
Kingdom will be ours
Saba sharpens her weapons
time to train her Apprentice
foreign
's first lesson
how to kill
he will learn by example
but not today
relax
the boy is spoiled
pampered
protected
he's been coddled for too long
Saba teases his bloodlust
but kills are still just play things
[Music]
he's your only son
the last in your bloodline
foreign
[Music]
give him time
greatness will come
[Music]
thank you
second as princes live a life of luxury
[Music]
they're growing strong
and independent
matsumi has done what she can for them
she is focused on the Next Generation
[Music]
the princess are second Karma's problem
now
every day he lets them stay
he gambles
the oldest Prince is hungry to do more
than backup father
testosterone fuels his Rebellion
his two brothers will follow him
anywhere
they think they can take on the world
foreign
[Music]
young calf Killers you have become
a coalition is forged in blood
do these princes really think they have
what it takes
[Music]
um
foreign
kills for Less
especially insolent sums
have you forgotten your place
curiosity gets the better of matsumi's
new Cubs
[Music]
move on little ones
your brothers need a lesson in manners
foreign
the princes must show respect
or they will pay the price
the northern Queens would kill to take
the marsh
and steal sakakama's
Exile makes the sisters bitter
hunger feeds their anger
resentment infects their cubs
the first kill is always the sweetest
[Music]
is this what power feels like
this isn't about Hunger
it's about dominance
control
my perfect little killers
[Music]
one step closer to seizing the kingdom
second Karma Knows little of the schemes
in the North
and cares even less
he risks leaving the princes to their
own devices
he has other matters to attend to
[Music]
hidden away
out of sight
second Karma has another
secret family
[Music]
with matsumi's sister
beautiful
the Aging King has been going behind his
Queen's back
this is Plan B
[Music]
one can know they exist
not yet
someday they will do second Karma's
bidding
but this little pride could also be his
downfall
the more he has
the more there is to lose
and while he's here
his sons have free reign
[Music]
foreign
yet to make a kill or even try
Neo still relies entirely on Saba
oblivious to the scale of her sacrifice
Saba has to work twice as hard to feed
them both
it's been days since their last meal
mistakes are now not an option
foreign
don't make a sound
[Music]
closer
perfect
dinner time
Neo expects his share
but Saba is tired of his entitlement
she who kills
eats first
wait your turn
salika
Saba knows this low-life well
her Shadow Army won't be far behind
um
they will steal this hard-earned kill
get to the trees
you will be patient Neo
[Music]
finally
Neo's turn
[Music]
an experience will be his downfall
he can't even hold on to dinner
[Music]
hurry Neo
zalika will kill for this
foreign
kill
but he's just not strong enough to drag
it to safety
[Music]
Saba can only watch a zelika confiscates
her prize
thank you
Neo has lost everything
including Saba's patience
she has had enough
her son is hungry
but Saba no longer cares
Neo has never known real hardship
could this ignite his will to kill
with sakacama away his sons size up the
throne
they're rich beyond their wildest dreams
the Envy of the realm
for the moment
but uneasy lies the head that wears the
crowd
there's an intruder in their Marsh
and as acting Kings
it's their job to protect the kingdom
[Music]
this Nomad was banished from his pride
for coming of age
foreign
as they should have been
he tries to hide
but the princes won't be fooled
they will seize any chance to wield the
power of the throne
[Music]
rally The Pride
the oldest Prince relishes his brutal
Duty
foreign
tastes like
out
breathe it in
the sweet smell of Triumph
they've proved they can hunt
they can protect
they will be Kings
[Music]
oh
they're growing confidence Echoes across
the marsh
[Music]
wrong
this second Karma's hold on power
slipping
[Music]
he hears their treachery
loud and clear
[Music]
treason
someone is hunting on Leopard rocks
right under Saba's nose
an accomplished killer
[Music]
dark eyes settles down to a banquet
for one
saber is hungry
but it's strictly Invitation Only
she might eat
if she plays her cards right
leave this to me Neo
lone males think nothing of killing a
cup
if Saba fails
she'll pay with blood
Neo's blood
Neo is ravenous
he smiles fresh meat
the property of an expert executioner
[Music]
foreign
can flatter him
Circle him
disarm him
charm him
how do you steal a meal from a big
hungry male
very carefully
[Music]
before
all right
stay back Neo
one mistake and he will destroy you
[Music]
but dark eyes yields
why
dark eyes is no stranger
here's your father Neo
dark eyes spares his son's life
this time
and Saba gets a meal
Neo is desperate for a taste
but the time for sharing has passed
[Music]
time for tough love
thank you
Samba is done providing for him
if you're hungry
go hunt for yourself
or starve
the bitter queens of the north do
whatever it takes to survive
their cubs were weaned by hunger not
privilege
all right
rotten meat builds character
the harder the life the tougher the type
suffering turns innocence to savagery
[Music]
our time will come
our kingdom will come
second come as Sons feel at home on his
throne
now his Queens are ready to mate
you can hunt
you can lead
so why not breed
well here's one good reason
the king is back
foreign
this is his right
privilege
these are his Queens
but the oldest Prince is brazen
how dare you
second Karma will put them in their
place
and keep them there
foreign
this is the job of a real king
the prince will not satisfy his last
year
not on second Karma's watch
across this line
and you will pay the ultimate price
foreign
[Music]
the king's orders are clear
obey my rules
or get out
this Tinderbox is ready to ignite
all it means is a spark
[Music]
thank you
foreign
has killed the likes of you before
you will be next
[Music]
thank you
there can only be one true king
and I am going nowhere
[Music]